we're all familiar with coca-cola but
this is also coke it said that clear
coke was a top-secret project made
exclusively for a thirsty red Russian
[Music]
during World War two coca-cola made a
global splash boosting American troops
morale at one point
Dwight D Eisenhower met with Georgy
Zhukov a Soviet General instrumental in
the defeat of Nazi Germany Eisenhower
introduced him to coke try this Zhukov
was hooked but after the war Koch was
seen as a symbol of American imperialism
and was banned from the Soviet Union
yeah nope not here so Zhukov called up
none other than US President Harry
Truman to send him a secret stash I'm
going to need coca-cola
Truman agreed to help Zhukov out alright
alright you got it he got the top dogs
at coca-cola to disguise its iconic look
they eliminated the drinks artificial
coloring but made sure the new vodka
look-alike still had that classic coke
taste they packaged it in street glass
bottles capped with a red star according
to a World War 2 coke wrap 50 cases were
sent to Russia
Zhukov got his fix he was never caught
with the disguised Cola and as far as we
know it hasn't been sip since
you